Where I come from
women are not allowed to speak their minds.
As the eldest daughter
in a middle class Bengali family in Kolkata,
I was 'raised' in a ‘proper’ manner.
I was told how to speak,
what to say and how much.
Even something as simple
as learning how to ride a bicycle wasn’t
easy.
Since I was a little girl
I always wanted to have my own bike.
But it took me years to convince my parents.
Finally they gave up and went to buy a bicycle
for me.
I remember I was waiting patiently at home
and dreaming about my own bicycle.
But when they came back,
they presented me with a sewing machine.
I believe that Sewing was more appropriate
than riding a bike for a girl.
When I came to Germany,
I could have left everything behind.
But I still want to reach out for those women
back home,
who are bound by their duties and social roles.
I want to show them new perspectives
and inform them about their basic rights.